Yee ha.
We're live.
So Sierra if you it's my Senate right.
Sierra right.
Ciara Ciara.
Yeah.
Okay.
Listen it's like Shandra Shandra.
Yeah.
Ya ya.
If you had describe your occupation someone.
Mm hmm.
How would you describe it in one word.
I would say humiliate tricks.
See this is what I learned about you from my friend Chris Ryan.
He told me you got gotta get this girl.
I'm going to talk to her.
And then I went to Twitter page a Twitter page is filled with some hilarious
stuff like one of them is about you sending poop through the mail and then it
was like one of the only times the post office opened up your box or they tried
to I asked him not to.
And they respected that.
Why did they want to open up your box anyway.
Well I put it in a box of a very expensive camera that I had and so when they
asked me like What is this.
I was like oh it's the camera.
And I said well how much was it.
And it's like well I got nine hundred dollars.
And so they're like Oh we'll have to repackage this and and then she's like
getting her like knife ready or razor ready to open it up and I'm like oh no
it's it's fine you can you can just leave it as is.
And she's like well if it gets broken it's your responsibility and all this.
And I'm like It's fine.
It's okay.
Well there was more than just poo in there.
There was like piss there's toenail clippings.
There was a vial of my spit like this guy had a hole like.
Value package for me.
How did How the fuck did you get started in this business.
You seem like a fairly normal person.
Granted I've only met you for a short amount of time and I seem completely
normal.
It's it's a really good story.
I was 17 years old at the time and I was travelling abroad I was actually
exchange student in Japan and I was really lonely like I say to the host family
and I didn't know any Japanese and I only spoke English and so I was online just
all the time like.
Me and on and on.
I mean this was kind of before MySpace or Facebook or anything like that but I'd
go to different like social networking sites and talk to people.
And one day this guy starts talking to me and he's a total pervert.
He's like into getting peed on and he really has a thing for like panty hose and
and so he strikes a conversation with me because he just thinks I'm very
attractive and all this.
And I was kind of like grossed out by him but it intrigued at the same time you
know.
And so I was like OK.
I'm talking to a guy online he can't do anything to me.
So I kept the you know lines of communication open and we'd talk here and there
and and he always tried to convince me to meet him.
You really want me to pee on him and stuff like that.
And I was like No I'm not going to do that and I'm going to do that.
I kept turning him down.
And then one day he was like All right look I get it you're not going to meet me
but I just I think you're pissed should be bottled and sold.
It's like I was like All right buy it.
And like I didn't think you serious those guys full of shit.
But I was like fine by it.
And he did.
He bought a 12 ounce like bottle just like this of my urine for ten or fifty
dollars and after that you specify the ounces that you had to be.
I don't think so.
Now I think just a bottle.
And so it was just a bottle.
Yeah.
Right.
And yeah From there I was like Oh there has to be more guys like this guy found
me on accident like this was just a mistake like what it would have been if I
went looking for guys like this I give you promoted it.
Yeah.
Or like kind of sorted out.
And so it's like OK I've heard of like women selling their used panties before I
know that's a thing.
And so I started searching to see if there was like a website that.
Like I could be on or something that catered to that.
And and I did.
I found this auction site that's just like eBay but it specializes in like use
panties or socks or pantyhose or anything like a woman can wear can auction on
the site.
And so I was like oh yeah this is a I'm doing this.
And I started selling all sorts of stuff and I've sold anything you can imagine
I've sold like my shirt my purse tampons like hair from my hairbrush my bathroom
trash.
What is like hair from your hairbrush go for.
How much can you sell that for.
I've always sell it once I think I sell off like a hundred bucks versus like a
good log.
Well the thing about my shit is it's kind of an interesting story.
So when I first started a guy I wanted to buy my shirt and I was like Yeah I
just won't do this because I think it's the.
I mean obviously the money but I think it's an interesting story.
And so this guy bought my shirt for like one hundred dollars and after that I
knew there.
You know I'm just I'm like I'm just it's on my panties and it's gonna grow as I
don't want to sell my shirt
anyways.
Fast forward to this year and meanwhile guys have always asked about my shirt.
I'm like I always gave them just the most large absurd number like price wise
and they'd always be like What the fuck now.
And then two weeks I was making money otherwise but someone took me up on my
offer recently for four thousand dollars to buy my shirt and he's since bought
it two other times this year.
So I've made a grand total of twelve thousand dollars off my shirt.
Now you pay taxes on that should you be telling say taxes.
Okay so what do you what do you like list under occupation.
I have a really good accountant that kind of takes care of all that shit
slinger.
Money comes from.
Like
I I make fetish videos and stuff like that right.
Video producer this is just ice cream or whipped cream rather for lack of a
better Cherry man cherry on top whatever so.
So you started from this one guy essentially this one guy.
Yeah have fueled your imagination.
Yeah yeah.
So I started seeing tangible things and then from there I figured out how to
open up like my own phone lines where I get paid per minute like like a phone
sex operator but I wasn't like talking sexy to guys.
I kept getting fetish guys that were really submissive and just wanted me to
berate them and talk shit to them.
And so you seek these guys out or did they it just kind of was the path that I
ended up taking because I just I started out doing this fetish thing and so such
just kind of was it because I like your attitude towards people that wanted to
buy your shit your panties like you fucking losers here it is.
What was that like.
No I think I I think naturally guys that went by that sort of thing or like want
that kind of treatment.
So I would get guys wanting me to treat them that way just like you know I'm
such a lowly loser and I want to be weird pathetic little toilet and stress and
everything.
Wow yeah.
And then it was like when I knew I could go about the sex industry in this way I
was like oh I want to do it I want to do that.
I mean I tell people what I do for a living I'm pretty open honest about it.
And for the most part people think it's really cool.
So I think I don't think I would get the same response if I were a stripper or
something like that but I don't think there's a thing like being a stripper.
But a lot of people do and there's less stigma associated with it.
So it's like I kind of found this weird loophole in the sex industry where I was
so odd and because yes I'm a Metro Oh yeah yeah exactly.
That kind of makes sense.
Yeah but why did it's this is a gig where do you have an exit strategy.
Do you do you look at the future and go out fucking shit and buckets forever.
Shit every day I so my shit songs like Keep friends of these assholes.
You got 12 grand a year easy.
Yeah well for one guy I'll do it.
I always said I'll do it as as long as it makes sense to do it.
You know open ended right.
But I try to be smart with my money.
You know.
I own a couple of houses back in Portland and you know I paid for my education
that sort of thing.
So I just try and save as much as possible because I don't think I'm gonna be
making as much money as I do now the rest of my life.
Yeah well there's probably going to be a drop off when you hit like 66 year old
shit's not worth twenty eight year old shit.
Is that Gulf shit.
Kill.
There's something about Guilford just MILF is still like hot but Guilford let me
leave her alone.
So do you do you have like a thought process as far as like you like OK what is
my.
Is that all you do.
Do you have another gig.
No that's my only job for years now.
Oh my God.
Whoa.
It'll be so hard for you to work like a regular job now especially would make
you think about like how much you can make by shitting into a Tupperware
container.
Yeah I know.
Think about like how long you would have to work in an office to make for ground
like you'd have done a month at least right.
I got a good office job is 50 grand a year right.
That's a good office.
That's a good living.
Yeah that's that's a thousand bucks a week.
But you got to pay taxes rent.
So the tax is chopped away.
So to actually get four grand.
Yeah.
I think about that a lot because I'm I'm very spoiled and I realize that that
that's a stripper issue too right.
So right.
Or like athlete issue like the one thing we're like Yeah you're making a lot of
money for my time.
Yeah especially like athletes or you know we're like when it's over it's fucking
over.
Yeah.
There's no you know it's like these Allen Iverson characters that make hundreds
of millions dollars just eat through all of it and you never planned on it
ending or having some sort of a right strategy to continue it.
Yeah so you're just gonna just ride that bitch right into the rocks.
Yeah.
Finish the plan.
Keep the throttle pegged.
I mean it hasn't.
It hasn't.
Lake gone down like I continue to make more money.
Well you're still young and pretty.
Yeah exactly.
But how old are you now.
I'm twenty nine.
Yeah.
So there's got a solid ten years for it starts getting really weird.
No way like 40 and you're still shit into buckets.
Boy Hey you know maybe you should not do that.
Or Oh no.
Why not one.
Just keep it if you're doing it now.
You enjoy doing it now.
Yeah it's great it's it's.
Then why stop.
Why am I talking about.
Why don't I just shut the fuck up.
Shut up.
I'm just thinking about your demise.
Why should concentrate most terrible aspects of your job.
It's hard not to but it's just so terrible.
What's strange but it's also like this is not normally like an interview that I
would pursue but Chris kept insisting that you were like really intelligent and
interesting.
Like he's like She's got a very unique take on it.
Like it's not just that she's doing this but she's just like a normal person
that while this is better than working as a waitress.
Yes it's better.
Oh it's great.
I mean I work for myself and so yeah I make my own hours and travel a lot and
actually travel and taking off to Southeast Asia after a few days in L.A..
What do you do in Asia.
Shit on people.
You have a guy there waiting.
No I'm just backpacking just travelling.
Oh my life.
So just doing that for non-work.
Yeah.
Yeah exactly.
Now why you're there.
Do you work.
Do you have.
If you have an internet connection what I do is because my bread and butter
right now are my videos I just shot a time like
October and September and all that.
I just shot a bunch so I'm all set up through February with my videos and they
just automatically.
I'll see you back them.
Yeah exactly.
Okay.
And so how often you release videos like five days a week.
And when you do them do you do them specifically for individuals or do you do
them for the public like you do both.
A lot of MA custom videos.
So guys will you know send me their fantasy and you know I'll charge them and
make the video and then I also really said to the public as well.
So like what's a typical fantasy that a guy will call you up.
Hi my name is Doug I'm a fucking loser.
Do me a favor make a video about how you want to piss in my mouth.
Doesn't worth
bother so many.
All I'll touch on on more recent when I had this guy is but for me pretty
regularly.
And all of his fantasies involve being in the dungeon and male chastity see male
chastity devices.
No I'm not shaming I've got it too.
It's basically like a cock cage and I don't like those words together.
Yeah okay.
So you put your dick in this little cage and you put like a little padlock on it
to lock him up and then like you know the woman the dominatrix or whatever will
wear the key and it's all about just kind of teasing this guy who can't touch
himself or get hard.
Really.
Yeah.
There we go.
Okay.
So what we're looking at for people who are listening to this if you would
describe it he would describe it as hood.
There's a couple different kinds.
Yeah some metal ones some plastic ones.
Some of them spikes inside them.
Do they hurt the deck.
Yeah.
They start swelling up.
So if they get aroused it's painful for them.
Yeah.
2 they take it off and they're bleeding and stuff.
Well it depends.
If the woman has the key to it she decides to unlock it basically.
So you do do you do.
Only videos or do you do like one on ones with these guys.
No I don't meet anyone in person it's online and all my videos I should specify
are like point of view.
So I'm talking to the camera so the guy feels like I'm I'm talking like to him.
So like this video I'm describing this guy.
You know he has this fetish for chastity.
So I have a habit with these little devices and I'll unlock it and I'll show it
to the camera and I'll I'll kind of move my hand in pretending I'm putting it on
you know.
And then I lock them up and then I tease Jimmy scroll up to the upper right hand
corner upper right above that right above that right about that.
What the fuck is that.
Oh it looks like it goes in your eyes.
Yes this is a giant Christmas tree looking thing that goes in your ass and it's
connected to one of those cock holsters.
Oh my God.
Yeah looks like it must strap you in that can't go off.
Yeah you've got this.
Pole in your ass and then your dick is locked up in a cage.
Wonderful.
Great idea.
This is ridiculous.
Yeah.
So this this one specific.
I like that you like that.
Well it's different.
Does that make sense it's for a girl.
It looks like the female jester.
And so this is like there's a whole fetish that goes along with this right.
Yeah.
The woman being in control right and kind of decides like when the man can be
released.
And so how do you do that in a video though.
The guy's nowhere near you.
So like I said I'll be looking at the camera.
I'm talking to cameras I'm talking directly to the slave and I'll take full
chastity vice and I'll all kind of like go into the camera pretending I'm
putting it on.
And then from there it's mostly just kind of like a tease show or you know like
rub my boobs together and talk all seductively.
And so the viewers watching it as though I'm like seducing them.
Do you think you have in particular it's pretty morbid so his fantasy is in this
dungeon and I lock him up and I have this nurse outfit and I'm his nurse and I
talk about how I'm going to train him
to be to to to serve me orally.
But what I do too.
So you can do this.
What was it.
I had to at first remove all his teeth because I didn't want teeth on my pussy.
So you know I banged his teeth out.
Yeah.
I'm just talking I'm talking about it.
So you wanted me to talk about you know taking his teeth out.
He wanted this.
This is like his his what is your job to.
I don't know if he.
Probably not in real life.
Anyway a couple of clamps in his ears to be steered you know.
And then he wanted me to tell him that his vocal cords would be removed because
I don't wanna hear him complaining.
Whoa yeah this guy fucking hates himself.
Well it's funny because he he was like Could you do it.
A very sweet sort of way.
Like he didn't want me to be like a real mean mistress.
Like he wanted me to be like that kind of juxtaposition of like oh really sweet
but I'm doing all these terrible things to you.
Whoa yeah.
Now what do you find.
There's a stereotypical occupation or a type of guy who wants this sort of
treatment.
I think I see where he might be going with this.
I get all sorts of guys.
I think there's this like kind of cliché that there are all these high powered
CEO right that want to be dominated.
I don't think that's the case.
I talk to all walks of life like young old rich poor alike.
And so it's just a fan it's like a foot thing.
Yeah.
Like just doing his thing a lick of humiliation thing that some guys just have
that gene.
Yeah whatever it is.
Yeah I know it's a gene but it's totally not.
Yeah you know I'm just.
Yeah.
The thing.
Have you ever tried to figure out where it comes from.
Have you ever like been like.
Because I would assume that like from the first time all these guys like you
know so much body piss you know people like what the fuck are you talking about.
Yeah but have you ever tried to figure out like what is wrong with these people.
All right you know what.
Did you get your perspective.
Well you know there's not a lot of information about it but like the best
explanation I've heard I know like Dan Savage talks about this and and the
author early Jesse bearing you wrote that book perv.
He talks about it it's like there's this kind of sensitive period for guys like
around the age of 9 where their mind is just kind of almost malleable in this
way.
And they'll usually have an experience that will you know set them off for the
rest of their life.
That hardwired them to like whatever they like.
I think for most guys that's like boobs and blowjobs.
But you know some of the time some some weirdo gets in there some people it's
just shitting in your hair.
Yeah and and it really seems to be just like really hardwired for guys like
because I as you can imagine a lot of my clients don't want to like what they
like.
It's weird.
You know a lot of them are submissive and you know guys aren't really allowed to
be submissive.
And so you know a lot of men really struggle with it and they try and like quit
it like they see it as this addiction that they need to quit.
Wow.
But you can't.
Like let's let's just how male sexuality works it seems like you can't just like
something else.
So you say you you think it's just something that happens along the way during
the developmental period.
Like a little hijacking of your of what we would consider normal sexuality to
hear it piques this interests or
gets this fetish fired up inside of a guy's mind.
Yeah I mean I don't like to speculate about that sort of thing.
You know I don't want to play armchair psychologists but like from there that
seems to be I think you've earned the position.
Yeah maybe so but I mean as far as like studies I've been on this like that
seems to be just kind of the best explanation that you have right now about it.
I've talked to Dan Savage about this.
And Chris as well.
Like we were talking about the guys that might not even be gay that get they
develop a fetish for a guy giving them oral sex.
I talked to those guys all the time.
Really.
Yeah it's not forced by the caller.
What's it called forced by forced by force by force by sexuality.
I thought it was for spy for spies.
Yeah.
No it's guys that want me to force them to like suck cock get fucked in the ass
and they'll tell me time and time again I would never do this unless a woman was
forcing me to do it or a woman was present encouraging me to do it.
It's a it's not about I want to suck a dick.
It's about I want a woman to humiliate me in this way because that's the most
humiliating thing I can think of.
See I guess I could kind of understand like fetishes I could understand like you
know just get really turned down when you see women's shoes or something wacky.
Yeah but there's something bizarre about wanting to be humiliated like that's
I'm shocked when I find out how many people have this thing where they want to
be humiliated.
Yeah.
What are they.
What are they tell you.
Do.
Do you ever have.
You have video conversations these people or audio conversations.
These people on the phone.
Yeah I talked to them.
Yeah I talked to like on Skype like I do camera phones one on one and so you see
them sometime if they turn on their cameras see them right.
And you know.
Depends on if they want to be seen or not.
All right.
I don't really care.
But I mean I'm mostly talking to them and it when they're aroused and usually
wants the comments like good bye.
So I don't have a lot of like you know post-coital conversations or anything.
Right.
So I don't know.
It's just it just seems to me like it's a different form of dirty talk.
Really.
Right.
So it's not necessarily that they really do want you to force them to suck a
guy's dick.
They want to talk about it and beat off.
Well they don't have a choice with me because I don't do sessions or anything.
Right.
But a lot of guys do like I'm friends with women who work as dominatrix is.
And yeah they'll want to set up a session where this woman like foursome just
like a deck or sell their house on craigslist or something like that.
And so they do it.
Yeah.
Totally.
That's next level shit.
Right.
None of them do.
I mean some commercials too scared but certainly guys that do but like the
ultimate for those guys is to find a dominatrix that will get them a guy that's
kind of fuck them in the ass.
Yeah.
Or forced him to suck his dick.
I had a guy one time is this French guy and he is really into the whole force by
thing and he was also into being like blackmailed and exposed for what he was
doing and so he made a video for me.
He put my name on his for head in big letters like sea air.
And his ass.
And then he just found like this black guy with just the biggest dick ever.
And just like made a video of him like blowing on with my name on its head and
then getting fucked in the ass and then he wanted me to put together a whole
video where I'm like humiliating him for this video and that I was going to
expose him to the world and expose them to all his ex-girlfriends and he fucking
loved it like it all together.
So happy.
And it keeps paying me money so I did more of it in the bag.
Why I this goofy French accent.
He's super flamboyant.
You'll probably watch this and be totally stoked and talking about him right now
actually.
Wow.
You know what.
So is he gay.
You he's super flamboyant.
Yeah.
Like I would think he was gay but he's apparently had girlfriends and part of
his kink is that he wants me to expose him to his ex girlfriends for being the
big fag that he is.
Oh my God.
Cause I need it.
I need to punish him for tricking all these women when he's really just a closet
fag.
So yeah that's his thing.
I mean he's clearly not totally straight but bisexual I guess.
I guess yeah because he's not coming to a man for this.
You know he's coming to me so he's obviously attracted to women.
But you can go deep with this one.
Yeah I guess maybe he's attracted to women or maybe he's dated women before but
always secretly wanted a man but knows that it would be humiliating so that he
gets his kink like pretending that you're going to expose him.
Yeah I mean maybe like you said Chris Ryan was saying once an orientation and
one's a fetish.
So it's like yeah it's a fetish for women but he's really gay the other way
around.
Didn't you have a situation where a guy like gave you his bank account number
and everything to and wanted you to pretend to steal money from now.
I get that thing all the time.
That's a normal one.
Yeah.
Well that's that kind of gets into financial domination where oh that's a
financial domination issue.
Yeah.
I have learned all these terms.
Forced by financial domination financial domination is basically where guys
literally get off on giving a woman their money.
Like that's their king status.
Like get off on giving money they get off on being blackmailed or being stolen
from.
That can be part of the can but a lot of guys like I get a lot of guys just
sending me money for no reason just like you got like and that's what they like
to do.
They like pleasing me they like sacrificing for me and that sort of thing.
And some guys kind of get more into the control aspect where they want to give
me their bank account number or their credit card number and watch me like shop.
Credit card.
He put a GoPro on and go to the mall.
No I usually do it online.
I did a a double Cam session with this girl one time and this guy put all his
credit card information into this Saks Fifth Avenue website you know and then
gave us the password and was like Go ahead shop and in an hour we spent ten
thousand dollars of his money just like buying just stupid shit that ended up
like reselling.
I don't give a shit about Slender handbags or anything like that but he liked
the idea of these like bitchy kind of Paris Hilton type girls that would just
laugh at him and just use them for his money.
Wow.
Yeah.
How strange huh.
Poof.
It's interesting though that these guys at least have an outlet now like yeah.
I know what they did before the Internet.
Do you think it is somehow the Internet because of the the access to people who
are willing to do this that it sort of fosters this or helps it flourish.
Yeah I don't know.
I've thought about that.
I've wondered if these fetishes even really existed before or if you know yeah.
Now these guys just have an outlet.
I have no idea.
Do you mind saying how much you make doing something like this or is this
something you ought to keep to yourself.
Like you.
OK I understand.
Totally makes sense.
Especially we talking about twelve thousand dollars just in logs you start
getting toenails and bloggers and all that.
Who knows.
Sky's the limit.
Yeah.
Have you ever had someone that you did this with that like insisted on meeting
you.
I don't know about insisted I I've certainly had guys like be really persistent.
But I mean the answer is just now.
I just thought of a guy I wanted to give you like a million dollars to shit on.
Oh I did that.
Yeah.
No one's offered me quite that zero.
But is there some other effort really.
But it's gonna be a guy out there that becomes obsessed with you and he's really
wealthy and he's like it's worth it.
It's worth it.
I film it for several camera angles.
Hire a professional crew.
Yeah.
I haven't quite gotten that offer yet but so most most of time people are
content with the videos.
So yeah.
Yeah.
You seem to do pretty well.
How many of them have the average asked to meet you in person.
Oh.
Pretty small percentage.
I mean it's hard to say like in terms of there's some guys I never talk to they
just buy my videos round and there's some guys who by Cam some guys by custom
videos.
So your videos are for sale to the public.
Like they're never never free.
Yeah.
I mean unless someone pirate some.
But yeah.
Oh OK.
So you have him on your Web site or something like that and then someone signs
up with a credit card and.
Right.
So I have access.
Yeah.
So I like a a normal subscription Web site you know like any kind of porn
website where you pay monthly and get somebody's video streaming.
Think like two or three hundred and then I have a few like pay per view sites
where guys can buy the videos individually.
And how much of your day is spent doing this stuff.
Mm hmm.
That's a good question.
I could have thought a lot and I wish someone could just like watch me and see
when I'm working and when I'm not.
Cause you know when you work for yourself at home it's this blend of like
working and then Facebook and then doing the dishes and then you know working
and so it's it's hard for me to say how much or how much time I really spend
doing it.
But I mean I put I try and put a lot of effort into it because like we're saying
before it's not go last forever.
So.
And it seems quite lucrative.
Yeah yeah.
It's it's very strange.
How does your family know about this.
Yeah yeah.
You said that with eyes wide open.
I was raised.
Yeah.
No they know.
What do they think about it.
My mom and I don't really talk about it.
The last time we talked about it was the first time I told her I had that
conversation go.
Well how did it is that my house and I knew like it was situations obviously I
wasn't working at Starbucks you know because I was making good money.
I had a fairly nice apartment you know about a car and that sort of thing.
So it was like I knew she knew something was up and so I just figured I might as
well tell her.
And
her response was I think she just kind of nodded and was like OK.
And then I just assured her I was like You know I'm really happy and I'm safe
and you know you don't need to worry.
And that was it.
She's got a reserved private person.
So I think you know it just kinda makes her uncomfortable to talk about it.
So yeah we don't need to.
My dad thinks it's awesome.
Thank you.
Well so.
What.
Yeah.
My dad thinks it's really cool.
Your dad thinks it's cool.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
What was it he's cool about it.
Well I think he was just very surprised.
I mean the same situation like he knew something was up and unlike my mom he
would make comments alluding to the fact that he knew something was up but
wasn't like Western Conference because well like I said like you know how does
one breach the subject.
Well I know you're shitting in buckets kid.
I know it.
Well I think he thought it was something like prostitute unquote.
Yeah I think he thought something maybe worse than it was like Gallegos and he
was alluding to that.
Well no he like.
Like I got like about a car you know.
And I was told him as working at Starbucks and he just was like wow kiddo
Starbucks is really paying you a lot.
You know like comments like that.
It's like I'm not buying this but whatever.
And then when I finally told on it he said like he kind of like stopped me at
one point.
He was just like you know I don't know what's going on in your life but I just
want you know that I really love you.
And I just need to know that you're OK and you're safe and and and that.
And I was like all right I should just tell him because he obviously something
else is going on his head that's way worse than it is.
Ryan SO I WAS JUST LIKE YOU KNOW I basically humiliate guys on the internet for
a living and I don't meet anyone and I don't touch anyone I don't even really
get naked and and you're just like why.
I mean just know.
Like so many questions and he's just like wow he's like that's that's amazing
you're a genius.
That's great.
Jimmy he said I said.
Wow.
Now we're dead.
Yeah.
Well he is he's gay so he's you know wow he's not a you go for whatever
information I'll give you.
You know is that the most traditional lifestyle himself.
So you know he's open minded he's cool.
I guess you have to be if you're gay.
Dad Yeah.
How did you when did he come out to me I was 12 years old.
Oh yeah.
What about your mom.
We're 20
now my parents have been divorced for like five years.
But at that point but we grow up very religious who grow up Jehovah Witness
actually so they marry young and have kids pretty young.
And
I was going to be one next question about how many of these guys that you you
deal with are religious.
That's a good question.
I don't know.
You know I don't necessarily take polls but there are some guys that like to be
humiliated for their religion one religion and in particular that I'd rather not
mention publicly.
But I'd rather not mention it they're too obvious.
Yeah a little fanatical Islam.
Yeah.
And to.
I mean you mentioned it.
So there's a guy who is a Muslim who buys your videos must be humiliated for his
religion.
Yeah.
No.
And there's guys that will.
I don't do this because I'm not touching on a 10 foot pole but there are guys
that will pay girls to like piss on the Koran and they're not Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
So it's it's.
And make videos doing that.
Yeah.
Whoa.
And there's good money in it because it's like so taboo like a thing that's so
taboo.
Someone's jerking off to it.
You know how hilarious is what you just said.
There's good money.
It's like.
You're saying that like it's a good river to catch fish and you know.
Like they got some nice trout in that river.
You might die.
Eating good.
That is what it sounds like.
Good money in there.
There's good fishing in that river.
Wow wow.
Fuck yeah.
I had one Christian guy that went to meet it to make a video of me like telling
him to denounce Jesus and worship me and jerk off in the Bible and I did that
video because whatever Christians are gonna are gonna come after me for that and
most likely Yeah most likely.
Yeah some pretty fun.
Jesus Christ.
How strange.
Hmm.
What a weird place to find yourself in.
Yeah.
Trapped in this or not trapped but just in this world.
Yeah a strange world of people strange fetishes and ideas and yeah kinks.
Does it make you like look I mean you must look at people so so much different
than most other young girls that like go walking down the street in Portland you
see people you don't I mean you've seen the man behind the curtain so many these
freaks.
Yeah well nothing really surprises me you know and I find that a lot of guys I
guess because I do what I do.
Like what is will tell me what they're into.
Just like just very openly about it.
Just because they know I'm you're not jaded as the right word but I was so
accustomed to hearing like the weirdest shit.
Nothing really surprises me.
I think a lot of people get paranoid that I assume they're into something weird
like a lot of guys like.
Everyone's always intrigued by what I do and I tell them there's like wow.
And if it's a guy they're always like you know they start asking questions but
then they backpedal and just be like I'm not into this sort of thing.
I just think it's that just dig it.
It's like well I didn't think you were until you said Is it weird with dating
and dating hasn't been a problem.
I've had it say three serious relationships.
I see that is right there the difference between men and women.
Yeah right there in a nutshell that you say oh sorry it hasn't really been a
problem.
You know why.
Because you're a pretty young girl so pretty young girls you guys like OK
whatever you do you shit in a bucket whatever we're gonna fuck yeah I can deal
with that.
But if you know but if a girl met a guy and the girls like what do you do for a
living is like well I take shits and bucket said I'm a dude.
Girls I feel like I'm out.
Said look I'm not handling I don't care how cute you are you fuck.
That's a good point and somebody threw it before.
What do you do.
I set my toenail clippings shit guys I saw it in underwear all day and I sent
them to dudes girls to be out there would never take your text.
Yeah.
And that's I think you probably guys would assume oh she's a freak.
Oh my God.
She's not going to say no to anything that's girls off the chain.
She's out there peeing on dudes we're paying for dudes.
Yeah that's a difference few men and women.
Men will tolerate so much more bizarre shit.
Yeah lot girls want to date like a stripper necessarily.
Like they get jealous and that's a little different.
That's different because it's what you know.
Or a porn star certainly.
Would be really hard.
That's that's a hard one.
Yeah.
Yeah that's a real hard one.
I've had friends of dated porn stars and then it gets to a point where it gets
kind of serious.
Yeah.
And you know these girls come home from a get like.
I.
Had.
A friend who is a writer who's a writer on Newsradio and he was dating this girl
who is a very prominent porn star at the time and they were at dinner and she
you know they were you know trying to have like small talk like normal people do
at the end of the day at dinner and he was like Oh so what's going on there.
Hi Ben.
She's like I just had this hard anal day with this guy pounding my ass.
I'm so tired.
Yeah.
And he was like sitting there like with his jaw dropped like Oh Christ yeah.
Just he couldn't do it anymore.
No other guy.
I got another guy another guy who was living with a porn star huh.
Dating living cool with it.
Fine.
No big deal.
Just her job man just her job dude.
And then one day she left a contract out and you know going over the contract.
Mm hmm.
And he looked at the contract and he's like.
Was airtight mean.
I know their timing airtight means a dick in every hole in the mouth one but one
the veg and I like submarine.
And he was like That's it I'm out.
That was it.
The phrase air tight on a contract.
He just realized what he was getting into it wasn't that his girlfriend was
going off and having sex with another man.
She was getting three men stuffed.
Now she's getting brutalized.
Mm hmm.
That's interesting.
I mean if you're okay with her your lady you know having sex with other men.
Like what.
How do additional dicks really make a difference to him it was just the straw
that broke the camel's back.
I know.
I mean I think he's probably close to not being able to take it anyway.
You know sometimes people get into things like it's not I it's not what they
want right.
But the girl is so much prettier than most girls they get so much hotter.
Yeah like I have a friend who's another one a different dude who has been living
with the porn star for a long time.
Yeah and then she retired recently.
She just does like videos and stuff.
But the whole time where they were together she was just getting gorilla fucked.
Yeah like four or five days a week.
And he's like this really nerdy.
Sort of like low key quiet guy.
And she's pretty hot.
Yeah.
And it's like the only way he's ever gonna get that kind of a girl.
And I guess in him she finds stability.
Sure.
And a nice a meet someone who's kind and you know and then she goes off and
gorilla fucked.
Mm hmm.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Right.
That's really what it's all about.
Like if it were who at the end of the day.
The real problem is our attitudes about sex that's at the end of the day.
That's where that's the only place it becomes a problem because if you're off
getting mass massaged nobody cares if you go someplace and three people massage
you.
Nobody gives a shit.
Right.
But if three people fuck you then we're like hey.
You're breaking the rules.
Yeah you know.
Yeah that's really like in the porn industry.
I mean they're getting tested every week.
So you know it's it's kind of hard to make the excuse that you know it's more
dangerous for your health because I think I think their population is actually
like it.
There's less instances of US studios than the general population are promiscuous
people and the general population.
That makes sense.
Yeah kind of makes sense because we have to like how many people do you know get
tested every week.
You know Jamie Jamie is three times a week.
Fuck yeah.
Using my fork he's just paranoid.
No I'm just kidding.
But yeah I would always think that.
Well if she gets tested on Friday then we bang on the next following Thursday.
Who knows how many dicks have been around since then infected Charlie Sheen.
You know that's what could happen.
Poor Charlie.
Who saw that coming.
Yeah no kidding.
Crazy Charlie.
Isn't that interesting Charlie.
For a guy is such a victim.
He is a victim.
He's a victim of circumstance.
The crack in the dick were in the same room at the same time.
He didn't know which one to smoke who the fuck I'm Tony Hinchcliffe now with
puns.
Do you.
That's a crazy story right.
Apparently he's like blowing guys but I guess you two enough drugs you know I
guess you get cracked down enough and you like who gives a shit.
Give me that Dick I'll suck it.
You know you're just off the fucking rails right.
Yeah just bisexual could be just needed.
Well there was a story a long time ago about a quarry game.
So it was Corey had Corey Feldman apparently said that Corey Haim got fucked by
Charles she sort of alluded to it.
Like when they were when Corey Haim was really young.
But you know films got crazy.
So who knows.
Allegedly.
Allegedly crazy.
Is crazy but you know I wasn't surprised.
Right.
We were surprised that Charlie Sheen got it.
Well he's got HIV or HIV curse of our pee politically correct on the show at
least.
That's super important.
He's got HIV.
Yeah.
No.
That didn't surprise me at all.
It's a total train wreck.
He's a freak.
Yeah right.
I don't know why people like celebrate him so much like he just seems like an
awful person like.
Well at one point in time what he did was the unthinkable because he was a
superstar right.
Two and a half men giant sit com on the biggest it comes in the country.
He had been in Platoon and Wall Street.
He was Michael Douglas's son.
I mean it is Jesus or Martin Sheen son Michael Douglas playing.
They were different names.
I forget what I'm talking about when he had that like tiger blood meltdown.
Everyone thought it was so funny.
But it's like it's like he has kids.
Yeah but that's because he was doing the unthinkable he was owning it.
And in this country what we hate is when someone gets busted doing something and
tries and they go to rehab.
Yeah you know.
God forbid you know like you get a quitter
no matter what you do.
You could get busted doing anything you know like Mel Gibson went to rehab
because he was yelling at a Jew when he got pulled over who's yelling the cop
calling him a Jew and he's like I got to go to rehab for hate and Jews like you
went to rehab didn't go to rehab for that he did right.
Yes you're hurting me.
Yeah I think they have a Jew hating rehab cop.
I don't think the cop was even Jewish I was just drunk and crazy but it's like
that.
That's what led him like you gotta you gotta make amends.
You gotta find something to get pulled together.
Gotta go to rehab to pull together.
That's the move in this country we demand that you go to rehab.
Yeah.
We can't even do the kind of rehab at home.
No not good enough.
Yeah I'm gonna go there.
Like if you cheat on your wife.
That's why I'm a sex addict.
Gotta go to rehab.
It a go.
Powerful and I have all this money and women will fuck me and nope.
No.
Rehab addiction.
Got it.
Got a problem.
Got a sickness got illness.
Gotta go to rehab.
That's what it's like an Amy Winehouse song would make people go to rehab.
Yeah well rehab is a fact.
When did they invent rehab.
I really want to know.
Mm hmm mm hmm.
And.
It wasn't.
Betty Ford wasn't I don't know.
She didn't she's the Betty Ford Clinic.
Was that the first one.
Good question.
I think you might have nailed it.
That might be it because that was what it used to be when I was a kid.
It was always oh you went to Betty Ford.
Yeah.
I was like what you would say when someone had fucked up and just completely
blown it right.
Yeah.
Do you ever get dudes that are former sex addicts like they have gone to sex
rehab and they've had counselors tell them that they need to stop and
I don't know but I'm sure I have.
I've never talked about it talked to any guys about specifically but there is
definitely a certain percentage of guys that think they are like addicted to me
and it could be kind of confusing because I think sometimes that's part of the
fantasy is that they're addicted to me.
But there are some guys that legitimately have a problem with their spending and
their drug off habits and just how much this fetish world kind of consumes them.
And they may make poor decisions and like especially if you get into the whole
like blackmail exposure fetish like oh yeah I had a guy one time
I really felt bad for him actually.
Nice guy weed cam.
And like he would dress up you know and women's clothing like and not like
classic clothing just like outrageous kind of bimbo like tutus and just crazy
slutty makeup and then he would get a bunch of used condoms and put them in his
mouth oh shit and then take pictures and he would and he would want me to like
you know pretend to blackmail him and threaten to send him and he would give me
you'd give me like real people's like email address like ex-girlfriends and
stuff like that already are you.
He was also one of the guys that would laugh when we make a video and release
it.
And so he didn't pay me a lot of money to make a video and release it.
And then like a week or so later I got an email from
a dominatrix that he saw in person and it was like a really serious e-mail and
she was just like hey you know I know you made this video for for this guy and I
was you know I just want you to know that he really struggles with this fetish
and he's he's kind of suicidal and he's really freaking out about you know that
you put this up even though he asked you to do it and I just want to kind of
reach out to you and ask if you would consider taking it down.
And so I did.
And.
Yeah.
I mean give me a match.
I don't know what you're into Joe but like imagine like whatever you're into
sexually and of it like that feeling you get were almost not quite
uncontrollable but it just kind of where you lose it a little bit sexually.
Because you're just so like intoxicated.
Like that feeling for you know being exposed in this way where there's condoms
in your mouth and you're like dressed as a woman and stuff like that and then
you come and you're like Oh fuck what an I.
A lot of guys like really struggle with that where they get their their desire
comes from this place of just something they actually really do not one really
like scares them and figure them out like it's just sex just so that's so
strange to have the the two contrasting sides sort of right next to each other.
Yeah.
Pre and Post orgasm.
Right.
Why I feel like we all maybe kind of share that a little bit girls too.
Well I mean.
Well I mean just the idea that I mean sex just normal sex is kind of weird and
kind of gross.
If you're not turned on you know like or like if you're like watching normal
porn like it looks really awesome and feels great when you're aroused and then
you comments like you.
Yeah.
Who was I.
It's like going together you know.
So.
And that's just maybe two very lower degree.
But yeah you go into these weird fetishes and that difference is much more
defined.
Well there's definitely a difference when you're there.
You know there's definitely a difference.
Like if having actual sex with someone and being aroused and then what it must
appear if you weren't horny at all.
Yeah.
You know.
Especially if you look gross naked.
Right.
You know people look gross naked then and get fucked they just.
And then when it's over the like Oh yeah.
You look at it all and you like what the fuck am I what am I doing what is this.
What is this weird urge that your body's natural reward system sort of been
hijacked.
Yeah.
Just to get you to come in someone's mouth and then what is this.
Like what is going on here.
And especially if you're a guy it's like it seems like you're here.
It was like cognitively impaired and your priorities are just almost yeah.
You're 100 percent driving nice the way I've described it is like when a guy has
an erection it's like sitting in the backseat of a really long bus or some other
dude's driving but it's hard to talk to him because all the windows are rolled
down and the engine is really loud and you yell and you know where the fuck
you're going you're watching your life take place through a dirty windshield.
Like where are we going.
That's it.
Is this so true.
And then once you have an orgasm all the sudden when the clouds of confusion
part you wake up and you're at the front of the bus holding out the wheel.
Yeah.
I mean like what the heck is going on here.
That's literally what it feels like.
Yeah.
To a guy.
But that's how that's how there's 7 billion people on the planet like that.
That switch that goes off where massive impairment of function of the thought.
Yeah it just gets shot down all those fused you start blowing off circuits start
shutting off.
That's how people made sure the 7 billion people on the planet.
Yeah it's true.
Especially back when people had never figured out soap or wiping or anything.
I mean who knows what people smelled like 200 thousand years ago but there were
people two hundred thousand years ago and they were having sex with each other.
You got those pheromones going now.
I mean barely.
Probably puts you over the top barely allows you to.
I mean the guys that we on by my underwear I wear it for a day but they want me
to wear it for a week.
Do you lie and say Don't don't say no I don't.
Of course you don't know.
Did they ask you to do things in the underwear like fart.
No.
Yeah I get that shit.
Oh Jesus.
And masturbate.
And anything that can secrete off my body if someone wants to know wants to eat.
Oh God
is there ever anything that people have asked you to do.
And he said no.
Meet them.
Yeah sure.
Well because I'm kind of you know I'm always in control and like the female Dom
I won't do anything that depicts me as submissive.
I don't get naked.
I get pretty close.
I get pretty scantily clad but I don't get completely naked.
Yeah.
That's that's about it.
If it's I mean if it's a video that I can just do.
Just me and the camera and I'm in control.
I'll probably do it.
I have guys ever tried to get you to not be in control of guys ever tried to
switch it around on you.
Yeah.
Pretty rarely though.
I think most guys kind of get Yeah.
They know what I'm about so they know it's kind of a lost cause to try otherwise
but once in a while they know what you're about that's Larry cause you got a
reputation in the humiliation world.
Exactly.
So fucking strange.
It's a strange existence.
It really is fucking weird but it seems like it's a flourishing existence.
That's what's strange about it is that there's obviously a certain percentage of
the population that wants to service yeah yeah.
And it seems like because I know I haven't been in the porn industry and it
seems like mainstream porn is losing a lot of money with piracy and whatnot.
I mean I'm sure they're still doing pretty well but they've lost most of it it's
been the bottom's dropped out of it.
The point where they make money now ironically is it really.
Yeah that's where they make money.
Yeah.
It's kind of funny.
Thing that's ironic really.
It's like Alanis Morissette Ironic.
It's odd.
Yeah that's where the money coming in gets that necessary pay per view to pay
per view in hotels.
Yeah but who the fuck doesn't have a laptop like who's doing them.
It's so like I've seen people even say like hey don't go to these free sites you
know you should support your local your performers and you know buy porn but
most people like whatever you know.
Most people don't care.
Yeah it's business but I see a lot of like former mainstream porn girls like
doing what I do now.
So it kind seems like it's kind of the new thing.
And there's something to be said about the more personal interaction and the
fact that there's no middle man.
It's just it's me you know.
When you email me you get me and write and control too.
Yeah.
Also that you don't have to worry about it.
You know that's that's got to be a big aspect of it.
Because if you're doing films and then you know you don't get to I guess maybe
you decide if you have that kind of power who you have sex with or what you do.
But if you want to make more money right.
To do other stuff you know.
Yeah it's got to be tricky.
Yeah totally.
Yeah I might.
I don't do anything I don't I do.
So that's pretty sweet.
Yeah I think in that sense the like the porn business is probably going to go
sort of the way of the record business in that.
Like the record business was controlled by these big groups and they're kind of
they're worthless now because no one's selling records anymore.
And sort of the porn business was like this big thing where like all these guys
who are the producers and the content creators like these companies these big
companies they were making millions and millions of dollars and the girls made
some money.
Yeah but they didn't make the bulk of the money.
They were the ones that everybody was paying to see but most the money was being
made by the producers.
Well that's fucking dried up and now the girls are kind of owning it themselves
now doing stuff like what you're doing.
Yeah and like a lot of the other one I see like different people on Twitter they
offer like videos and stuff like private videos they'll do with people.
Yeah.
And I think I mean if a guy is even the slightest bit fanboy ish they like that
their money is gone directly to the person and not you know.
Yeah.
Yeah yeah.
Well sure.
I mean there's a lot of that fanboy shit too.
That's for sure.
There's fat like.
I don't think people who are outside of the business or aren't in somehow or
another know somebody in the business.
But there's guys that are like fuckin sports fans.
There's sports fans of porn stars like they wouldn't want to get like
autographs.
And they they like their fans like Oh yeah well the avian every year they have
the whole e convention and it's all just the girls signing autographs.
And what kind of freaks show up at those things.
It's fun.
I go to your every year.
Because one of the clips for sale on the sites that I sell my videos off of.
They have a booth and so I'll go over there and sign and it's so mainstream most
guys don't know who I am but everyone's smile they will.
But yeah it's kind of like whatever you imagine a guy like that would go to
that.
You're probably right.
It's exactly what you're picturing.
Yeah but that's also honestly to the same dudes who go to comic book
conventions.
Yeah you know the same dudes are really into baseball.
You know we could all be in that group.
Yeah let's throw a few wrong turns or right turns.
Depending on your perspective.
Yeah.
We have a weird thing in this country particularly about sex and anything else
where you're really into it.
It's it's OK you can be addicted to playing golf and everybody has somehow
there's Jamie he's on that golf course every day.
That's crazy fuck.
But if you're at home beaten off every day you're a freak.
Yeah you're a loser.
You know you could have gigs and gigs of porn and you just really love it.
And you talk about the old days and you know you have like like you know like
Mike Tyson needs to watch like old Jack Dempsey films and learn technique.
You know like
you can't be like that with porn because if you like that with porn you're a
fucking loser.
Yeah it's weird.
It is weird.
I mean as long as you're getting everything else done in life it's not
interfering in any excitable way I guess.
I mean even if it is getting in the way so is everything else.
People get addicted to those food people that are nuts about food.
People that love gambling.
Yeah
that gets in the way everything gets in the way but we look at those things as
somehow or another being somehow or another being a better thing to be addicted
to.
Mm hmm.
Yeah preferable Yeah.
Yeah I think you're right.
Yeah.
Yeah we're a little fucked up about sex for sure.
A lot of fucked up sex but whatever.
Right.
I mean that's how you pay the bills imagine a perfect world where everybody was
open minded.
Would you have to do you'd have to be working at Starbucks just like you told
you.
I know all these guys would be honest with their wives about what they're into
and then they never come to me for it.
Yeah so it's probably better that we live in a strange world.
Jamie world.
Yeah I think so.
Echoes of the Puritans who founded the strange country.
What did you go to college.
Yeah.
What did you go to college for.
I studied psychology.
Perfect.
Yeah.
Minored in business.
Oh perfect.
Jesus Christ you're born for this.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
So this is a perfect gig for you.
Yeah I think so while I fit right into it.
I don't know how much longer we could talk about this but I think you kind of
nailed it.
I think I've had a feeling this is gonna be one of those podcasts.
Yeah.
How long has it been an hour an hour an hour and 45 minutes.
Okay.
Can I can I do a little selfless Sean short so please do some self impression so
I haven't mentioned this at all publicly yet so I wanted to save it for this
podcast because I know you got a pretty big audience.
I have for the past couple years been working on a documentary with a filmmaker
Julian Shaw from Australia and he's been doing a documentary on me filming me
and we just opened up a Facebook about it and we'll be launching a kickstarter
to help fund the rest of the movie pretty soon.
So if people want to join and get updates it's Facebook dot com forward slash
ruin me movie.
So it's essentially a documentary about what we're talking about here about me.
Yeah about humiliation about how these guys want you to do these things to the
exact threaten them.
Yeah and we've filmed a lot of it mostly through private investors but we're
gonna do some crowd sourcing here soon.
So yeah it's gonna be called ruined me.
So it's uh yeah Facebook dot com fraud slash ruin me movie for updates on that.
All right beautiful.
Thank you.
Thank you sir.
Very nice meeting you too young Jamie take us out.